good morning John you may have noticed
but I am not particularly head shape hi
I'm Sabrina and just started University
so as you may have guessed I am falling
apart my love of naps and my hatred of
myself has made it so that the only
thing that keeps me warm at night is the
dumpster fire that is my life because as
it turns out it's really hard being a
human being
everybody is stressed out by different
things depending on their work the
relationships their age I mean babies
are just out here trying not to throw up
on everything and I also that too as a
university student I've got midterms
presentations essays readings and
suggested problems but we both know what
they mean by suggested all right I'm not
saying that you got to do this I am
merely suggesting that you do questions
1 to 44 or else bad things might happen
that's a weird accent and I won't like
you I would probably be crying myself to
sleep if I was getting some sleep but
are you ready for the big pot with
revelations I am the happiest I have
ever been in my entire life I know it
seems a bit paradoxical but before you
call Stockholm Syndrome consider the
possibility that we build this false
dichotomy around stress and happiness
that happiness exists if and only if
there is no stress but I would argue
that for most of my life the biggest
hindrance to my happiness was a lack of
stress good stress not social anxiety or
a crippling fear of failure no I am
talking about the stress that comes
along with doing something that you love
so desperately that it fills up every
hour of your day and sometimes even more
it's like when you only have 15 minutes
but the TV show you're trying to watch
is 30 minutes long it shouldn't be
possible but you always find a way now I
didn't have that sort of stress growing
up because I could afford to be so lazy
privileged but because of that I never
worked very hard I could never
experience the fulfilment of pushing
yourself to your limit of success after
spending so long at chipping away at a
challenge granted that challenge might
be a course where everything is just gay
and the midterm is tomorrow but let me
put it this way I remember sitting in my
first-ever math lecture taking my first
step towards a math major and realizing
I don't know how to do math I have made
a horrible miscalculation probably
because I don't know how to do math and
that realization should have destroyed
me my entire life plan is probably gonna
fail just like me in math class but
instead
collapsing into this little stress
singularity I remember smiling maybe it
was just a coping mechanism but I like
to think that it's because I am so
enamored with knowing that there's so
much more to know and now here I am
arguably too aware that I know nothing
but for the first time in my life I feel
like I am working towards something the
factors that are stressing me out the
readings and the writings they're the
same factors that build the framework
for my happiness I can't spend all of my
time feeling nostalgic right pathetical
futures when I have a paper due at 11:59
on a reading that I'm not even sure that
I read because I read at least 200 pages
this week and my eyes can only do this
so much before I accidentally hypnotize
myself and when I do have free time I
spend what I have left napping but what
I have left after that I spend truly
appreciating my life my friends and my
family what I'm trying to say is that
I'm the most stressed out I have ever
been but the happiest I could ever help
and it is so good to know that those
things are not mutually exclusive and
John I'll see you on Tuesday